the jurogan experience there's uh
occasionally you'll see a fighter that
does something
very artistic and striking that sort of
elevates the standard like did you see
the derrick lewis cyril gone fight no
you need to see that it doesn't knock
out that der clue's got a knockout right
no serial gun beat the [ __ ] out of him
oh [ __ ] he shut him out he shut him out
like it was a shutout for i think i
think he stopped him in the third but i
mean cyril gone who's six foot five
247 pounds moves like 170 pounder
it's crazy he's he's bouncing like
wonder boy like bouncing like this the
entire fight bouncing throwing faints
like completely changed the standard of
heavyweight striking and i'm not
exaggerating i watched it three times i
watched it today in fact i watched it in
the gym today while i was working out so
better than like in god in terms of
movement in terms of he's like the best
moving heavyweight there's no question
he is the best moving heavyweight i've
ever seen no question
the best moving it doesn't mean that
like this is the way he fights like look
at how he like
every time derek lewis goes to set up
to move towards him cyril gone is
nowhere to be found he lit derrick lewis
up man and eric every time derek lewis
comes to him like look at that jab
i mean his movement in terms of closing
the distance is spectacular that front
leg front kick to the body
and
i was severely impressed i mean he had
beaten a lot of really good guys like he
beat jarzinio rosenstrike
he beat junior dos santos whose best
days are behind him but you know he he's
beaten some very very good fighters but
to watch the way he beat derrick lewis
who's a legit one punch knockout threat
and the technical
acumen that he showed the skill the
technique the footwork the movement the
understanding of distance the ability to
control everything that happened inside
the octagon was spectacular that's art i
it changed my opinion of how would a
fight with him and francis and ghana
would go down at first my thought is
that francis ingano has the nuclear
option with everybody he he has such
[ __ ] power so so does derek lewis so
does derrick lewis but
francis and ganu
he has the hydrogen bomb derek
they both they both have crazy one punch
power
but
when you watch cyril gone you go
man how the [ __ ] does anybody it's it's
like
francis has
excellent technique francis has
ridiculous power but he doesn't have the
movement that gone has the question is
can francis
deal with the movement and and maybe
threaten him in a way that derek lewis
didn't figure out how to and that's what
makes the fight so interesting yeah but
the the way that guy moves
is something special man it's i mean you
only saw like little highlights of it
there but i've watched it pretty
carefully the in the three times that i
watched it i can't think of a single
heavyweight that i've ever seen move
like that and there's no flaws in his
clinch game he understands like how to
how to avoid the takedown he understands
pummeling he understands distance and
where he's safe where he's not safe and
and what to look for when he's pulling
out of the clinch to not get hit it's
really amazing man he's on a [ __ ]
real high level and he's undefeated so i
think he's not i think he's 9-0 now or
10-0
so he's gonna get a title shot well he's
the interim heavyweight champion now oh
that was for the for the heavyweight
which is weird right he's like and gano
just won the [ __ ] title he's not
injured it's just like the ufc and in
ghana where it's some sort of a weird
impasse so they decided to make a uh
interim title which brings up all sorts
of you know
ethical
discussions about what is what is an
interim title when is it
if the organization can just decide oh
the negotiations aren't going so well
we're just going to have an interim
title like how many months after the
like when did he fight stipe
when did francis singhano fight stipe
let's take 20 20.
was it i think so it was definitely
during the pandemic because it was at
the uh november or something like that
it was at the uh apex center march 27th
of 2021 yes
yeah
so it feels like way longer ago five
months ago yeah five okay five is long
that's kind of crazy yeah you know like
how much time do you give a guy before
you know he defends his title the
difference in boxing is so different
like boxers go they long stretch and
boxers enter into negotiations and
negotiate like caleb plant and canelo
alvarez they've been dancing back and
forth as to whether or not they're
supposed to fight and the negotiations
fall apart and they they come back
together again and now they're
supposedly in negotiations again for
november
you know boxing is so different watch
the entire episode for free only on
spotify